[Music]
what's up everybody Welcome to hey babe
this is hey babe we said what so Sal is
not here again
Sal's Not Dead by the way a lot of
people are tweeting is Sal Dad no he's
not dead because if he was dead you
better believe I do a patreon with his
dead body so so Sal is not dead South he
would do a lot of Impractical Jokers
episode yeah they would sell wouldn't
they they would finish the Impractical
Jokers would finish the season and he by
the way who would be the only one left
there'd be one Impractical Joker left
because they're dropping like flies yeah
and then mer would be the one yeah Murr
would kill them all
um yeah so so I think that um uh uh Sal
is by the way just doing uh he's just
got you know practical joker stuff he'll
be back with us uh after Thanksgiving or
hopefully before so do not worry but in
the meantime we got a good friend of the
show good friend of mine Neil Brennan
yeah let's talk how do I know Chrissy D
well
let me explain you know me
you opened for me I did in uh probably
10 years ago in um Jersey if you're
thinking Neil
uh an Italian coming off a hot Letterman
set is that really the guy you want
opening for you in Jersey in retrospect
no
it was not the guy that I wanted open
for me in Jersey because uh neither one
of us really knew how to kill but I
would I would say the audience liked you
significantly more than they like me
um I don't have a fine I don't have like
a clear memory of it but I remember
going like [ __ ] all right just every
show would be like [ __ ] I I also had no
draw in New Jersey and I and I continue
to just go we don't got to do jerseys
you know what's wild about just like
perspective and like the human brain is
I remember this these exact moments as
completely different I remember you
being sold out wall to wall and me
saying to myself how do I get to a point
where I could sell tickets like him and
you absolutely crushing isn't that wild
that's very funny isn't that wild to how
it's like we were both there but we saw
it through different lenses and and um
and yeah that's because when you were
set because when we first brought up
where did you meet me I was like wait
where did we did and then as soon as I
thought about I was like oh Jersey and I
remember it so and I remember you eating
falafels in The Green Room which I was
like you know me being an uncultured
Brooklyn boy I was like what's a falafel
can I dip it in marinara sauce
uh now I'm I haven't been on Staten
Island it's been a while right now on
Staten Island do you get an amber alert
when there's like some some cocky blacks
around that you've run them off the
island like there's some cocky blacks we
get it there's some black kids hanging
out in the corner we gotta get rid of
them yeah and then you guys all round up
and honk your horns and and it's Italian
flags it depends if they're Democrats or
Kanye blacks
if they're Kanye blacks we accept them
if they're Democrats no uh Kanye blacks
they stay Kanye black she said yeah we
like we yeah we like we don't no I'm
kidding no you know what's interesting
about Staten Island and you go like this
you guys are smart
it has a Vibe a lot of people when they
think Staten Island they think oh uh you
know like racist Republican sandwiches
all these things are true but but
where we live on the North Shore of
Staten Island is not like that at all
actually Staten Island where uh to be
fair I'm being honest where I live on
Staten Island and this area we're
filming the pond is some of the most
culturally diverse some of the most
cultural diversity I've seen in all the
five boroughs it's I I didn't know it
existed I moved here not for that reason
I I moved here and and when I found it I
was happy you know because my kids now
go to these schools that are like so
culturally diverse I saw yoga studio not
far dude yeah no box from here it's it's
it's well but you and I both know if
there's another 911 it gets burnt down
yeah oh yeah yeah on on 9 12. it's burnt
down the day after by the way any
terrorists listening to the show and we
know that you are if you want to really
sabotage in New York City then you have
to do two things one do what you did on
9 11 knock down the buildings but then
the second move is blow up the Verrazano
Bridge because all the cops and firemen
live on this guy yeah so you couldn't
you wouldn't able to get anybody to help
if you you they forget to break this
bridge the Verrazano Bridge this is this
part I do love the image of a bunch of
240 pound guys swimming
angry swimming like these [ __ ] well
I'm coming for you you yeah
owl heads it's the George Washington
painting Crossing the the Delaware but
it's a Vinnie falzone just a fat piece
of [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] fire but um no it's
um it's it's one of those Staten Island
is is it's I'm I'm actually really happy
to be living here they got a lot of
history here a lot I love history they
got a lot a lot of history on stuff do
they really dude the Revolutionary War
Colonial history this was the borough of
the island it wasn't Burrows back then
but the island of Staten Island was the
first place this is where the British
troops the the general set the King
George III said the entire British Army
directly to Staten Island there's like
if you take that that's the call in New
York's a very important Colony take
Staten Island will win the war and then
they immediately took Staten Island in
they took by the way as proud new I'm
proud New York at the tough guy Staten
Island Brooklyn the colonial are the
British Army took Staten Island in about
20 minutes we just completely laid our
weapons down we're like you guys win we
were wrong we said we should have never
said nothing and then New York was fully
occupied by the British for the entirety
of the war how'd they get rid of them
they they they got rid of them the the
British just left when the war ended but
the for the entirety of the war for all
five six years there was no this was
complete British people on inhabiting no
are you following
um
uh uh Ukraine like are you like kind of
interested yeah I'm I'm uh I'm I'm
interested I'm interested in I guess
now I am and I'm not what I'm what
because I don't believe I don't I just
don't believe what uh we're being told
is the truth I don't think that Ukraine
is winning like the news says their way
I kind of don't either but then they
then then Russia leaves Kirsten in these
cities and I'm like oh maybe maybe I
think that I do think that yeah in in
it's it's a complicated thing I think
for America to understand because like
Ukraine like you know like Kiev is like
that's like part of like Russian like
Foundation like this this is It's like a
sacred thing that they are together to
some of them to some of them right like
one of them pootie very old pootie yeah
they really are although what's his name
uh uh zielinski got a new jacket huh
yeah so let's get a real is that a North
Face like not dead I mean we should be
celebrating every I mean this guy
everybody thought he was going to be
murdered immediately and I gotta say put
on some weight though he did that's
interesting right in a war where you're
supposedly being the most shown after
guy you're getting fatter he gets
diabetes he's still eating his feelings
what's on your mind this is a cry for
help go ahead well I mean I just yeah
the the the the the the Russia Ukraine
stuff I've stopped I I don't really
watch I don't pay attention not that I
don't pay attention I think I have a you
know we have an obligation as Comics to
pay attention a little bit but I know
try not to get sucked into it my uh my
kind of um routine has been lately I
watched the local news just just the
local news uh and uh are there a lot of
those uh take makeovers here what do you
mean the Tokyo Drift take Corner
takeovers La you watch the local news
every night they're like youths have
taken over the corner of Bundy and and
Slauson and they do like it's a bunch of
it's like a hundred kids or 200 and they
do the spinning and then one of them
gets clipped and it's [ __ ] fantastic
no dude for us it's every night it's
like somebody pushed somebody else in
front of them yeah yeah I think it's
just so it's just like but now it's like
not even tragic anymore they're just
like delays on the seven you know why
you know they're like they're like you
understand it's going to be it's a bit
of a clue it was this time and what
happened what happened you know and so
there was nothing we could do but you
know I I I think I why do you keep
pulling this oh what is this eighth
grade teach in Arizona or husband have
lost their school jobs after recorded
only fans videos in their classroom I'm
okay with that recording oh eighth grade
teacher and her oh they were having sex
they made a porn only fans in the uh
okay in the classroom they work at you
know where I love [ __ ] can't do it
while we're doing this yes you know what
I love on a bed yeah just find a bed
yeah yeah you know what I mean
missionary yeah missionary on a on a on
a on a nice uh uh podcast mattress on a
mattress that sponsors a podcast yeah
you just pick one yeah [ __ ] on it that's
it that's the way I like to if you're
wondering because I I I did you ever
find yourself doing something you were
like this and it's not even me right
yeah yeah
having sex in the shower it's like for
what you're gonna slip my dick isn't
angled out way it's stupid I always get
shampoo in my pee hole yeah and it's
itchy
um speaking of shampoo in the pee hole
let me tell you sponsor Neil yeah I well
no they've that that shampoo one no more
No More Tears unbelievable they dropped
us
um what's up babe brand new hour of
stand-up material I am in Toronto right
now we got two shows tonight at the
Royal two shows tomorrow night Friday at
the Royal then Saturday in Buffalo all
the tickets at christycomedy.com then we
got uh December uh in mid-December 15 16
17 we got Charlotte Asheville Charleston
and then December 31st Huntington Long
Island the Paramount New Year's Eve show
and uh January 12th 13th and 14th New
Orleans Dallas Houston christycomedy.com
for Ticky Wiki's brand new hour of
stand-up material writing tension wrong
move I love you Neil Brennan's Netflix
special blocks
um is I gotta be honest man it's one of
what you here's what I think number one
it's I would say on Netflix specifically
it's one of the best specials on Netflix
that I've seen in the last five years
maybe more one of the best two just in
general I think what you and Ari shaffir
put out back to back is like a
game-changing event for stand-up comedy
because they're both Specialists I know
you did it with three mics but I Even
though three mics was great I think
blocks is even a higher level
um jokes more jokes and more jokes you
know uh uh as as vulnerable that the
level of vulnerability that the
quickness of vulnerability followed by
comedy is so insanely hard to do and you
do it like really really well where even
Jasmine you know my Puerto Rican
girlfriend who like doesn't know
anything about comedy she was like
looking in and she was like that [ __ ]
was deep and funny like she's like
saying that like you know and she's like
listen and then you're talking at one
point about like you know how marriage
isn't for everyone in jail with me like
you need to marry me like it's kind of
like she was in bed like you know like
Neil had points about like let's just be
living in free and I'm like Neil yes
I [ __ ] gotta have this kid on the Pod
and
we're doing a double up I'm putting them
on hey babe and so and yeah I was like I
gotta get on get him on the bigger
platform yeah and and so and so and
behind the paywall and so yeah and so
and so but but what it is is is is is
number one it's special it's a special
because it's genuinely special it's not
just a comic with jokes in front of a
screen not doing a press conference like
like the like the like the last two
specials I put out you know I'm proud of
them but if I I wouldn't say that
they're special they're jokes that you
can see in a comedy club where I'm like
but that's all I had right yeah but what
Ari shaffir did it I think what his
special Jew that came out uh two weeks
ago why why are you call them that I
know it's well it's called you I thought
it was called [ __ ] Jew but it's
called it's called Jew and and and uh
and and so and so [ __ ] silence
yeah yeah that's Dan Island yeah and and
some
yeah we put in Jew and then satin Island
search engine's like do you mean [ __ ]
seriously but do you mean [ __ ] yeah
yeah not for nothing but do you mean
[ __ ] yeah and so and so so that was
great special because again it was
thematic it had a it it you know the set
was designed in a way where I'm paying
attention for more than the jokes again
vulnerable I'm learning yeah I haven't
watched it his set looks excellent it
looked it looks amazing fire hazard like
you can't [ __ ] imagine a lot of
people died but you but but but your uh
special was very similar in that way
where you know the set was amazing it
had you know at the blocks and you're
pulling out these blocks and it's like
all like you know these things that are
in your mind and then and then but I was
watching it for for so much more than
the jokes even though it was the I would
say it was a weird thing like the way I
could describe it is is the emotion I
felt the most like it was the funny
first funny first but I was listening
but the jokes were second in a weird way
I don't know if that makes sense yeah it
was overall I would say absolutely 95
percent funny but but it wasn't about
the jokes it was about the telling of
them it was about the point of them it
was about where it's all going and then
tying it in at the end when you said the
individual thing the individual ones of
these thoughts I can manage with it's
the totality of these thoughts that
causes my anxiety I was like wow I never
I slowly took the gun out of my mouth
and put it down yeah yeah yeah great so
first of all thank you for watching it
yeah because I know just watching
it's probably we all act like it's this
huge sacrifice to watch each other yeah
but it's I I watch pretty much everybody
right
um I haven't watched ours yet so what
I'm going to but um but I watch
everybody and so I thank I most Comics
don't yeah
um but I actually like comedy yeah and I
don't act like well if I watch you it'll
[ __ ] them it's like whatever which is
[ __ ] it's just a way to like not uh
give your friend attention so thank you
for watching it yeah and uh and and
thank Jasmine for me I mean look she's
not gonna let off with the marriage you
know she's not but like you got two
weeks I know yeah but but I appreciate
you buying me time watch my next special
is going to be me doing blocks with a
yamaka on like I'm just trying to
combine
um well what do you now when you see
somebody if Ari's thing is thematic yes
my thing is thematic yes do you ever
think like I should do one of those and
then how
how do you think you would what would it
how could you do it well that's what you
know it's interesting because it's it's
I'm in a weird place right now I will
also say you're more charismatic than me
and Ari like you're you're like people
just like don't say right people just
like
I said that in my head yeah you should
be like [ __ ] just how you do it you
go huh okay you think so but in my head
I'm saying obviously yeah yeah
um do you get compared to Tony
Hinchcliffe on every YouTube video
because I do
um uh uh I'm get I'm on Rogan today I'm
gonna get shellacked in the company
trust me she lack because if hinchcliff
look alike well no that's we talk about
information and covet it's gonna go
pretty well for me his fans are gonna
hate me my fans are never gonna hear it
yeah
um so so uh
so you're more charismatic so I think
when you do these shows people just want
to be around you right do you know what
I mean like people just want you to go
like they want you to do the you like
crazy like they want you to do Chrissy
blanks they want you to do all the [ __ ]
you're known for they just want to spend
time with you it's just that I get to
spend time with Chrissy that's like more
organized than the Pod and and like it's
fun so inside I feel like not like I
have to do shows like this but I feel
like in order to make it as fulfilling
as the guys that are just amazing like
Burr Dave or Chris or Jim Jeffries or
like list of millennial like list people
I'm forgetting but Wanda Sarah whatever
uh ali uh is there anything everyone
do I did I pronounce it right yeah all
right
um
yeah
um I won't say it I'll I have to play
Arabic I play Indian music behind me
when I say yeah otherwise I said Arabic
because I'm not racist
um because I it's all one thing
um so you don't have to do a thematic
show I'll tell you that I I I'm not
gonna keep doing them if I unless I have
ideas well because people DM me
by the way the amount of DMS I've gotten
is like on it's like overwhelming which
I can't believe like it's hundreds a day
right hundreds of like thank you and
like you got to keep doing this you
gotta I'm like I don't have I don't I'm
not gonna force it right like and
overwhelmingly positive right oh yeah
yeah like one kid said something next
like yeah one kid like you're a [ __ ]
and whatever whatever yeah
well well I I I
think that what because you said do I
ever think about it what's actually it's
made me think about or like watching
yours more yours specifically is like
I've been getting by a lot in my career
these first 10 years on just the
Charisma on just like you know I can you
know I I work hard I'm always you know
traveling trying to write but I'm like
there's a lot of times where I'm just
like not looking at my notes and I'll
have like a good set because I'm getting
away with things that were given to me
when I was younger because like I had
dad and my uncle that would like you
know when they would pick me up uh you
know my parents were divorced and they
would pick me up to take me from my
mother's house in Queens back to Staten
Island and I would sit in the car with
them it was immediately them making fun
of me saying you look gay nice kids and
so I had to develop like quick things
Charisma like how am I going to get
people to like me because I felt like my
father and his brother even though they
love me it's like that their way of
loving you was like I'm gonna make fun
of you and abuse you so I learned
quickly how to like you know get people
to like me quick or try so so when I
think about when I watch your special I
was like huh I was like maybe it's not
me it's not obviously what you do I have
to find my own way but it's like you I'm
gonna have to if I want to get to like
the next level now I'm gonna have to be
like okay so you have your gifts over
here but now you have to sit down and
you have to write and the scariest part
is you have to do it by yourself there's
nobody that's going to help you there's
nobody that's gonna you can't call and
talk to your friends about do you think
this you're gonna have to just figure
out why not because I feel like you even
know you think that you probably got
like a lot of I know for a fact that all
came from within you you wrote
everywhere oh nobody writes [ __ ] from I
mean like 100 no no uh one this girl
Casey gave me a tag
I mean a lot of it's like like rock was
helpful in like arguments right like
rock someone who said like if you were
married with kids you'd be more popular
I don't say it because I can't be like
and then Rock was like and I was like
[ __ ] you right by the way I won't spoil
because watch special but the Chris Rock
joke in your special with that the
Netflix party was a [ __ ] a thousand
yeah and it was so good and the reason
why I loved it it hit so much it was a
great joke on its own but it came less
than 30 seconds after like an insanely
vulnerable part of the show that there
wasn't laughter yeah part of it like it
was just deep where you almost felt like
Neil could kill himself on stage right
now that this that could be it's like
when Carmichael came out said he was
getting his HBO especially I'm like yeah
he's going to commit suicide on the show
somebody's gonna have to yeah I mean if
you really want the hits yeah uh if you
want to get an overall at Netflix you're
gonna have to kill yourself yeah um yeah
so but but I thought again watch it you
know but but I don't but why don't I a
lot some of those I mean none of these
the vulnerable part Ridge wallet baby I
love it I've been using it the thing
that I love about this wallet the most
is it prevents you from digital
pickpocketing which I didn't even know
was a thing but literally someone can
come up on you and steal your credit
card info if you don't have this type of
Ridge wallet uh if you don't have this
type of wallet it has like this titanium
stuff that blocks digital pickpocketing
so thank you so much for that Ridge
wallet and it's sleek and it's cute and
it holds all my cards and holds my cash
which I don't have any right now but it
holds it right here on that strap and I
love it and it's uh they got all
different colors over 30 colors Hennessy
performance carbon fiber burnt titanium
has over 50
thousand five star reviews durable
material meets each each wall durable
material means each while it comes with
a lifetime warranty let me tell you
something this is durable because I sit
on this thing with my big fat ass all
the time and it's great Rich team is so
confident that you'll like it I love
when companies do this because this is
how you put your money where your mouth
is and I love you for this they're so
confident that they'll let you test
drive it for 45 days and you can send it
back for a full refund if you don't love
it it's made with that RFID blocking
technology that protects you from
digital pickpockets like I said and
right now if you go to ridge.com hey
babe you can get the wallet ridge.com
hey babe do it let me know how you liked
it sorry hellofresh everybody hola
Fresca we love it you know that when Sal
and I are here we talk about hello fresh
actually that's why Sal couldn't make
the podcast today because he's literally
drowning in hellofresh boxes because
he's just got a full shipment and he
just couldn't even come to the Pod
because he's eating his way through all
the new hello fresh meals and I'm gonna
eat him so right now if if you go to
hellofresh.com hey babe65 and use the
code hey babe 65 you're going to get 65
off plus free shipping that's
hellofresh.com hey babe65 use the code
hey babe 65 65 off plus free shipping
they have all different types of meals
they got Christmas themed meals now
holiday theme meals
um I it's so much cheaper it's like 25
cheaper
um than going to the grocery store my
family and I love it we've learned we've
been learning to cook with it um it's
awesome we got the whole family involved
hellofresh I personally think it's the
best meal service uh uh uh plan on the
market and if you get a great discount
if you go to hellofresh.com hey babe65
use the code hey babe 65 65 off plus
free shipping hellofresh America's
number one meal kit
I'll tell you how I did the I had all
the jokes like just jokes and let me
know if my cabs are showing like this
much yeah um let me show you the eye
washing bracelet while we're here you
guys this it's fine everything I do is
usual sponsored by Ayahuasca
um there you go we're gonna talk about
that the uh we don't need it um the it's
on every other podcast
uh the I had all the jokes I wrote all
the just like the material right and
then I was looking at it going like what
am I saying like what am I getting at
and what I was getting at is like I feel
very defensive about my life choices
right and I feel shitty about them right
and I'm like constantly like I was I
could have called it like self-defense
that special like right just [ __ ]
constant like defensive about
again not being married is I don't it
people don't like it they just don't
like it like you're like committed to
like famously committed to your girl
right
and and I mean you know most of the time
yeah but
um the uh uh yeah well I'll tell you
what I'll tell I am I am because I'll
tell you what changed well no it just
got it I don't want to [ __ ] life up
I'll tell you I'll tell you what changed
I'll tell you what what my thinking
change it's crazy that that this and
this is like it's funny like sometimes
like the way like a street guy talks to
you is like even though they they it's
not as um you know poetic as uh as like
a famous therapist or it's not as well
researched he said a guy I won't I won't
you know say it I'm on the Pod because
he said he went through this so I don't
wanna I don't want to do it but but he
was like um he was like listen he was
like when you when you uh he goes you
know if if a guy has a gun to your head
and he's like talk to the FBI are you
he's got a gun yet he says tell me you
know tell me tell me what you know or
whatever like tell me the secrets you're
not gonna say anything you won't say
anything because you're like then
[ __ ] kill me I'd rather die than be a
rat don't just [ __ ] kill me I'm never
gonna tell you what I know I'm not a
[ __ ] rat and he says but if I but if
if the guy if the criminal then put the
gun to your daughter's head and put the
gun to your wife's head and said I'll
kill them you're going to tell it like
that yeah he said well cheating on your
spouse is putting the gun to your spouse
and your kid's head you're killing them
you're not killing you you're killing
them so every time you think this is
about you it's not about you it's about
them and then that thing once once you
have a thing where you're like oh [ __ ]
look at that that's it's oh it's always
been a it's it's about them it's not
about me it's once you have children
it's [ __ ] about them yeah it's about
your life it's about your wife it's
about all that stuff so that that's the
point that rock was saying is like if
you if the audience thinks you're like
that then they they like like they just
like you more right I think a lot of it
has it's all Charisma because it's like
and the reason I I mentioned Melanie in
the when in the run in that area
Melanie's selling more tickets now that
he's not married it's like it's he's
just because he's [ __ ] hilarious so
like they like you for like the reasons
right they just put a bunch of stuff on
you I think you seem committed even if
you weren't you seem like you're truly
like I'm just waiting for the right girl
well here's what's here's what I will
say is definitely something that shifted
in my brain is
if you told me not everything in my life
anymore is the amount of ticket sales
and the comparison to peers anymore
because if you told me hey you can sell
this many tickets if you're single or if
you just do this joke about someone and
it'll go viral and then I wouldn't do it
I'd say you know what I'm happy the way
my life is the way it is not like I I
think a lot about now like like
emotional money like I'm like okay I can
have you know a million dollar 10
million dollars in the bank but if
that's gonna cost me all this time away
from the kids and all these things
then in 30 years I may have a lot of
money in the bank but I'll have no
emotional Kevin Hart only sees his
family at photo shoots yeah I'm kidding
yeah yeah so so I'm like I I don't wanna
I don't wanna
um do that you know like I'm like I'm
happy the way my shit's going now at the
pace it's going and then if at some
point you know things like really slow
down I just have confidence in myself
that I'm like I'll be able to find money
like I'll be able to get I can just get
it I'll get it somehow you know because
I stay true to who I am and I'll get it
but I I the time with my family is the
thing that you won't get back the money
well that's the yeah that's the that's
the tickets you'll always find a way to
sell them you can you we'll figure it
out yeah yeah get on the right you'll do
something you know but I'm like I'm like
but but but so so with with your special
you know I thought too there was a lot
of just [ __ ] great points that like
it's like you know when they say oh
don't make a joke about uh you know it's
very hacked to make a joke about like
Asians aren't bad drivers but then like
on a special five years ago Bill Burr
did it Asians are bad drivers joking
it's like a mind-blowing [ __ ] joke
cause he's talking about Tokyo Drift and
he just does it if you're gonna do it
you got to do it like the best one
you've seen I feel like you know a lot
of people talk about like Republicans
and Democrats and all the politics stuff
but your stuff was so like like the
Republican joke I'm not going to spoil
it but a republican joke were you about
the NRA about how like we you know like
like Republicans think that they they're
they're hoarding weapons thinking that
they're going to take on the government
so like that bit I was like it was so
good where I was like yeah it actually
in a way like even subtly changes my
mindset on like hmm maybe Republicans
aren't right about everything you know
you know where I was like oh it's it's
that deeper you're like oh you look at
now you look at I'm like hmm look at
that look at that a little differently
now and I was like interesting like I
want my boys to watch it but I'm gonna
have to tell my boys I'm gonna have to
tell my boys listen to what this woman
has to say no yes that's fine yeah
because if they if I tell them you're a
guy they'll be like I can't do it he's a
[ __ ]
I can't
hear this queer merch yeah
but I was like I was like that that was
that's what was cool about it was like
oh this is like mind change this is like
um uh this could be like you're gonna
change some people's minds on stuff who
watches well that I the with that joke
well that joke here the the so that joke
yeah I don't want to give away punches
it's a joke about the and like whatever
how the NRA how the NRA thinks that they
could take on the government right they
could take on the military right
better act outs than you think based on
this flat affect yeah
um I know I noticed that too by the way
was like somebody's been going to
[ __ ] act down yeah [ __ ] act this
guy said took that that dancing class
took off yeah
um the uh yeah I danced twice
um
uh but what you liked it because one of
them is making fun of blacks so you like
that yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
um five more push-ups maybe maybe uh if
you edit it definitely for your friends
like ease them into some of the queer
areas yeah
um so open with me you know slide
whatever anyhow uh that NRA joke I
called uh uh Dave and I was like hey has
someone done this joke and he goes you
pitched me that joke in 1993. wow I've
been sitting on that [ __ ] premise for
30 whole literally because I was like I
would just think it every time
they would say like we need in case the
government is like yeah dummies they you
[ __ ] bought them better weapons yeah
you pay taxes to arm them yeah
yeah you're not gonna get them with a
[ __ ] yeah with your [ __ ] uh do you
have an a cat wow an AR-15 what yeah um
they're gonna get [ __ ] smoked yeah
yeah no I I I you know I I was like
because that's unless you're willing to
live in a cave right Afghanistan
Afghanistan Vietnam it was a tie it was
a time they tied us yeah because they
were willing to live in a cave for a
decade yeah cave yeah we're not good at
finding cave dwelling people we don't
know I mean look you want to live yeah
we can't beat you I I you know I feel
like um too like like with um with with
all that stuff when I was watching it
just from a Comics point of view I was
like how the [ __ ] do you even work that
kind of special out because it's so much
of it has got a you know like the stuff
behind you is of so much a part of the
show and you're wondering where it's
going to tie in and then all ties in the
end beautifully but I was like do you
just work that out like when I did it in
um
I did it on the road this like summer
yeah no
uh and index cards at the Irvine Improv
and uh and uh uh they and I would just
do it without it I would close I would
basically close with the Chris joke okay
like the because it would crush oh my
god dude it was CR
I even in the Netflix when I say the
last word in the joke about Chris yeah
the audience is too loud they're yelling
before I'm done right still yeah because
Chris doesn't care he likes kids [ __ ]
good job it's like a clean head pop me I
pop him back yeah yeah I was doing the
joke before Will Smith though that's
interesting yeah that that's I didn't
want to ask you that because that gives
away punch lines yes you brought it up
that's [ __ ] wild so you literally it
was almost like Jesus yourself I had the
joke yeah and he got the he got the
takedown yeah in the show later on I
would call back and call him an [ __ ]
right but and that would work but like
he got the joke and he there was a point
where he was getting the biggest laugh
in the show which I was like this cannot
stand dude and then when you when you
talked about the there's a part where
you like you know you get personal when
you say I didn't know this I actually
never knew this it it that you were one
of ten children yeah where it's like
dude thank life is so much about timing
because today one thousand percent
you're not you're not making it no no
dude the first your three oldest are
making and that's it and that's it yeah
I don't even know if Kevin would have
made it Kevin's Kevin's top three oh
Kevin would have made it then yeah yeah
um
yeah I I interesting but I was like wow
dude to be one of ten that's like an
unheard of growing up being one of ten
it's just like yeah man you must have
had to fight for [ __ ] identity and
love every second of the game but the I
cut it out but my parents
my dad's one of 13. my dad's actually
one of 14. my dad was a twin
his twin died Jesus when they were kids
and before that his mom was super proud
of the her twins yeah and then one of
the twins died so that was her she
thought God was punishing her for being
prideful so therefore she was never
proud of anything again for as long as
she lived real [ __ ] Irish depression
[ __ ] this is a 30. dude so many the
Irish were the original Puerto Ricans do
you wanna I say it more than white
Puerto Ricans yeah yeah we're white
Puerto Ricans yeah you want to know how
crazy Irish people are and I cut this
out of the show and you're gonna love
this I'm gonna I can't set this up
enough you're gonna love it you're
really gonna I love when people go like
you're really gonna like the story take
it let me decide
um uh the Irish during World War II
neutral yes couldn't call it yeah they
just couldn't figure out like which we
don't know you know yes he's he's
Exterminating people but he's also
bombing London so this is a mixed bag
for us yeah
J uh uh FDR and Churchill were like what
the [ __ ] is wrong with you and they were
like we don't know something though
something's definitely wrong with us
yeah they wrote Germany a letter of
condolence when Hitler popped himself
yeah that's how crazy the Irish are they
and it was all about because they hate
England they were like well [ __ ] you
yeah we're sorry yeah yeah we're sorry
for your loss yeah yeah sorry you're the
great viewer yeah no it's yeah I dude I
almost I almost got into a I don't want
to say Can syllable level uh thing last
week but I was in a I did a I had chosen
Boston the show in Boston last week and
the night before I was like I just want
to run around do some bar shows work on
something what show where to do so last
week in Boston I did Comics come home
you know TD Garden so it was like you
know it was one of like 10 guys on the
lineup so I was there the night before
and I said you know what let me just run
the set for it like let me just [ __ ]
whatever and I did like three or four
shows and then the last show was like
you know 12 30 in like Boston somewhere
some like basement bar show like
whatever so I drop in and there was like
a Japanese and white kid like half
Japanese half white in the front row
diesel kid whatever and I started you
know doing a little crowd workers end of
the night whatever and then he he said I
forgot what he said I forgot what I said
he said but he said something like he
said to me oh yeah just like a white guy
picking on my race and I said hold on
wait a second oh he said just like a
white guy being racist picking on my
race and I said wait hold on wait a
second wait a second I said do you know
do you know history like at all because
we were talking a lot about history he
goes he goes uh he goes yeah he goes he
goes I know I know because he thought I
was like full German he goes yeah I know
you guys were the bad guys in World War
II I said didn't you say in the
beginning of the set when I asked you
what you were that your mom was Japanese
and he was like yeah I was like do you
know how disgusting Japan was in World
War II that was like I haven't did it
good and you'd get him make him bring up
rape of Nam King on his phone yeah yeah
I was like that and I was like my mom
was Irish I said so really you your race
is only the vagina you come out of I was
like so I came out of a beautiful Irish
scone vagina that was [ __ ] neutral in
World War II bread like Irish soda bread
you came out of a vagina that was
bayonetting Chinese babies yeah and
doing experiments yeah I was like but
white people aren't we're the bad guys I
was like you suck I was like and I'll
tell your ancestors they suck and it's
somehow in [ __ ] liberal ass like
college kid Boston I got people clapping
which as a comic makes you feel gross
I'm like no no please don't clap yeah I
need a bit I need a joke I need I need
material don't don't please don't that
makes me feel [ __ ] disgusting but
then I was on stage at TD Garden I was
like should I bring up rape and then
King 19
000 white people I wonder if they'll
clap at this but but um but yeah no that
that history I brought it up because
yeah that [ __ ] Irish part of uh being
neutral in history is uh it's very
interesting because yeah they're just
neutral people and just more here that's
interesting okay here we go Irish pimp
just found this how are Irish soldiers
treated after World War II you would
think that after finding Hitler's armies
that returning ex-servicemen would have
got a Heroes welcome home but they
didn't instead they came back to a
country that was scornful ignorant of
and indifferent about what they had been
through in many cases they face open
hostility Irish soldiers yeah oh yeah
because some Irish did fight with like
the northern Irish fought there was a
thing last week on NPR about the black
soldiers in America yeah they would not
see pows were treated better than black
American soldiers yeah just awful [ __ ]
like look if you're Googling yeah you
know knock yourself out
um uh it's uh yeah but so so yeah Irish
people are inside and then my mom's uh
one of four and her mom died when she
was an infant and then her and her
sisters got they didn't even think guys
could raise kids back then so her dad
was just like I'm single again he had
four daughters
but once the mom died the mom before she
died like pawned her daughters off to
her sisters right like it didn't and
then the dad didn't even he was like
done right and then he started a new
family
with a new wife and like so my mom and
her sister should have all split up one
got sent to Ireland like just crazy and
couldn't come back because of Hitler's
blockade
that's what I'm saying like it's been in
your DNA to be like you just have to do
comedy you have to do something to
[ __ ] express yourself because
everywhere you look in your life there's
people just being like yeah I don't love
you yeah and I don't even know how I
don't know what are you talking about
yeah like what are you I one time said
some of my mom about having uh like
empathy for herself and she might have
gone like what the [ __ ] are you talking
about right on my phone why are you
calling me saying this [ __ ] like
they don't even have a vocabulary for it
it like didn't exist right there was
really no like parents weren't really
like nice until the late 90s right like
the parents didn't really have to be
maybe early 90s they had to be nice but
like before that they just had to be
like yeah effective yeah just keep you
alive and I'm a disciplinarian and I'll
hit you and you just have to listen to
me like it was all about parenting used
to all about you don't make me look bad
your representation of me where now it's
kind of like we're a team yeah you know
and do you feel like it's better
I feel like when I do feel like in some
ways is the type of parenting that
Jasmine and I do wear like we definitely
you know just have to discipline them
but obviously we never hit really I mean
send them to their rooms don't work
because they just have some [ __ ] iPad
that we don't even know about that they
just then watch in the room or you know
her brother well they'll just like find
what they got with their influencing
money yeah exactly yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's a business decision now they have a
tick tock because it provides I mean we
wanted a new pool so so
um no but I do think that what I I don't
know for sure but it feels like my dog
our daughter will tell us more uh will
be open with us more about things
because she's less fearful of like if I
say anything to my mom or dad they're
gonna scream at me or hit me because we
don't really do that with them so we're
the hope is that as she gets older and
their needs that there there will be it
come a time where like she's gonna need
to say something important to us that
she would have otherwise be scared to
she can tell us and we can all get get
through it together you know what I mean
and you like it you really like being a
dad right I do yeah I by the way I don't
know anyone who does it like I every guy
I know who's done it who didn't who was
kind of indifferent or like no no
loves it you know why I love it because
it makes me because there's so many
problems in the world there's so many
things that the human mind can just
consume and be like oh that's that for
me it's literally everything in my life
is okay including if something negative
was happening to me as long as I have my
daughter loves me and my and my and my
kids are like Daddy like we love you and
they're safe and happy and healthy then
literally everything else is like I can
tolerate it what if they're attacking
you on Twitter if right well once that
happens once that well here's well the
good news is I'm I I've removed myself
from social media so I I like I let
Venetia take Venetia takes all the abuse
now so I let her yes which is yeah she's
slowly losing her hair I was wondering
why she was smoking menthols yeah yeah
yeah so
so so
um um but yeah she's if my daughter's
well the thing is if my daughter does
start attacking me on Twitter and she's
above 18 and she's gonna get [ __ ]
roasted like everybody else yeah because
you know she's a big girl and no but it
is it is it is this thing that it kind
of um it kind of like uh saves me from
like especially our business or really
anything like in the world where I'm
just like I care to a point I care I ca
it it doesn't floor me with depression
and anxiety anymore because I'm like
well even if there's a nuclear
apocalypse I'm like well if I'm gonna I
got a 40-day supply I swear to God we
talked about on the planet got a 40-day
supply of fettuccine alfredo that you
just mix it with hose water which we
should have still even if there's
anything you'll be you'll you'll scarf
that [ __ ] down probably 15 days yeah
easily 15 days and I was like as long as
as long as I'm with them then that's all
that's all that matters because
everything else is kind of like
irrelevant where I'm like yeah but like
this connection that I have with the
kids because the thing is with children
is is you don't choose them they're
given to you you know you choose a
partner right even subconsciously you
might but the children it's like I had
no choice in why I was given this one
I'm just giving this one so it's like
it's okay so you think of it that way
yeah I know that's the only people in
your life that I believe I had no choice
you have no choice in family so to me
there's something very powerful and
spiritual not that but I think daughter
or son is a seems to be the highest
level of connection and or spiritual
connection because there's a
narcissistic quality involved in it I
think because it is a piece of you it's
your DNA and you and you are always
going to think about us first no matter
how much the pope will think about
himself first you know it's at
subconscious levels and different it's
just so I think I'm like oh I take that
in because there's the narcissist but
there's also parts of her that are not
you
or what's your what's your girl's name
again Jasmine Jasmine not your Jasmine
Jasmine shout out Jasmine shut up thank
you I think you're really yeah a lot of
my takes in marriage we've been getting
them pretty good yeah um you're probably
on the spin bike watching this yeah
um the uh the the spin bike it's called
Soul cycle or it's called Peloton don't
be this I didn't want to write you up
for the old for the 90s vernacular yeah
spin what do you call the spin cycle the
spin bike the spin bike and you said
diesel which I gotta think people don't
say anymore like what diesel like you
said the kid was diesel which I gotta
think dude Staten Island I'm telling you
we're about 15 years behind okay great
yeah yo no those shoes are mint no
generally the colors yeah
[Music]
um the uh the but all right so aren't
there parts of it's you there are parts
that are you and Jasmine yes and then
there's parts that are not you or
Jasmine and is that the part
I have a working Theory right now that
there's like our eternal spirit and then
we're dipped in the family stuff so it
becomes like 30 30. right 30 30 just
like Eternal you 30 mom 30 dead yeah I I
I I don't I think that that's 100
entirely possible because there are as
much as our both my kids are like us
there there's a lot of parts you're
right that's like that's an individual
characteristic who knows where that came
from but still I do feel like well for
whatever reason my our souls have been
put in charge of this Soul so yeah
there's something connected that I just
don't understand that I'm like you know
other people change like people change
in life like your friend when you were
10 may not be your friend when you're 30
because you genuinely have different
brain chemistry from 10 to 30 so you may
be actually different people like Yeah
from a scientific level you might be a
different person where my children I'm
like even scientifically as my brain
chemistry changes and so does theirs
there's a spiritual connection this Soul
connection that I I just don't ever see
how it's it's like an unbreakable bond
that but guys it's no secret that women
love beards and no I am not anyone's
beard we love growing them we love
having them we love scratching them I've
been trying to grow my beard out a
little bit you see but this is all I can
grow but I'm telling you it's gonna get
longer don't you worry about it I and
when it gets long enough beard club's
gonna help me right now if you go to
beardclub.com hey babe and you take that
beard quiz you're going to use my code
hey babe at checkout they will recommend
a grooming kit that's tailored to your
beards needs they got the pt45 trimmer
it's truly a beer changing device they
got the growth kit which features spray
to strengthen and moisturize your beard
here that's what I need the growth kit
features spray to strengthen and
moisturize your beard hair oils the
prime follicles for optimal growth and a
Derma roller that rejuvenates dormant
hair follicles no matter what type of
beer you have beard Club has the perfect
kit to fit your nears beard Club over 2
million beards served beardclub.com hey
babe use the code hey babe 20 off your
first order I'm gonna get that growth
kit I can't wait to get it but I but
what's funny to bring up the parent
stuff
it seems like our parents or certainly
my parents had no
understanding of that right or even care
like it's kind of like what why would I
experience right eternally I'm half
human half of it like yeah do you think
your parents had any of that no I don't
right I'm assuming your dad didn't but
you're [ __ ] on your cats no you know
what you know what interesting I think
both my parents love me the same I don't
I'm not talking about love I'm talking
about the this
Chrissy was given to us right and we're
this is we're in charge of this soul
and [ __ ] like that right
um huh I don't know because my dad gave
me a note that he wrote I was born
August 26 1984 that he wrote in the
hospital August 26 1984 that he gave to
me when I was 25 that he literally the
same piece of paper that he had saved in
boxes through moves through different
pairs of jail jail yeah
it had residue on it brown residue and
and blood and and then it was everything
from the Civil War but it was his ass it
was his ass baby it was a note that kind
of talked about his gambling addiction
and all the demons that he had and he
was like you know you're saving me I
just want you to know if if I die or if
you know things are not going good with
your mother and I if I'm not in your
life at some point I just hope you get
to read this letter and know that like
for whatever it means you're saving me
right now your little body that he was
like I don't even know you but I promise
you you're saving me and then he kept
this for 25 years and then I swear to
Christ I might have said this on pod
before but I swear to Christ he gave it
to me and I lost it in one week
great I lost the letter but I did take a
picture of it on my phone to text my mom
to be like mom do you think this is
Dad's handwriting or is this just
another [ __ ] scheme and then so you
have a yeah I have a picture of the
letter that I talked to my mom but I at
the actual letter that he for 25 years
but it just goes to show and you know
what I my dad was not even mad to find
out about because you know what he said
he goes oh yeah he goes because it
wasn't your responsibility it was mine
he was like you you read it once and lit
it on fire because did you save him from
all this gaming like just stopped yeah
he stopped he stopped for the most part
yeah he I never knew my father to ever
be in trouble or gamble or or or you
know not not when I was a kid at least
no and he was a very active father
always in my life divorce from my mom
never made an excuse on why he was just
always like yeah I'm there I'll just be
there um so I think my love for my kids
comes from my dad my mother loves me a
lot too but my dad had to like you know
my dad was like I got to take a train
and a ferry and two buses to come see
and all this [ __ ] like the 911 [ __ ] and
like
do you are you like do you think of that
what you consider like embarrassing or
maybe like not the best move are you a
hundred percent with him on it
like like like you mean like what like
like threatening teachers and all that
[ __ ] I think that he's got I think that
he all he saw was I love my kid I think
that's all he saw was so I think that
hit his way about things maybe I would
say like my new hour of material is
called right intention wrong move
because I feel like that's what my dad
that's how I describe my father right
intention wrong move yeah so I'm like
I'm like um uh you know he always the
intention was always good it was always
like I love I love your mom even though
we're divorced I love you even though
you're making mistakes and I just love
the idea of being your father but then
the moves to kind of you know deal with
situations maybe weren't right what
mistakes were you making when I was oh I
mean you know I mean trouble on that 911
thing you know getting into a fight
um you know uh uh look we were it was an
emotional time it was I know but you
know still like fighting you know not
listening to my mom like my dad only hit
me once in his whole life he only hit me
once in his whole life because he was I
was not being kind to my mom I was right
13 14 year old raging teenager and my
mom you know was like you know asking
simple things clean your room you know
[ __ ] you know don't bite the dog you
know don't piss don't piss in the house
like you bit the dog yeah I was like an
[ __ ] of a child you had like 80d and
all that [ __ ] yeah but and not and then
later in the late 90s it was like not as
signed like I went on we didn't have
science till like 2009. dude I know we
didn't have science till Dr fauci the
pandemic and and so and so and so and so
I you know that it wasn't like the or
wasn't in therapy like I remember like
you know occupational therapy like I
still hold a pen like an [ __ ] because
I went to Catholic school so they would
just be like oh you'll pray you'll you
know just pray that God will hold the
pen correctly for you and it's like no
I'm I'm holding the pen like I [ __ ]
lobster claws and it's embarrassing in
public when every to this day I just
signed in in Equinox in Boston they were
like you hold a pen like that that's we
all depend weird I'm like yeah sister
all Mary never that's Boston though so
they're going to [ __ ] on whoever yeah
yeah they're like you see how it holds
the [ __ ] pen you're like you hold the
pen like a [ __ ] Yankees fan it's like
what all right um so um so but but my I
was being a you know a brutish team
where would you bite the dog you know
just on its [ __ ] legs like I would
just grab it and bite it and make it cry
and really yeah I swear because it would
bite me I'd bite it back or I'd like you
know I I peeing in the hampers not
listening to my mom Pampers hampers yeah
I would multiple yeah like you know like
the the delivery guy would come you know
I'd I'd [ __ ] answer the door [ __ ]
butt naked and like you know like do
[ __ ] like you know push steal his bike
like being just stupid and then and then
I called my mom a [ __ ] one day like a
like I didn't like because I I don't
remember what it was but I call my mom a
[ __ ] and my mom told my dad
and then my dad uh came over like you
know a couple of days later and he was
like uh you know he's like hey he's like
uh what's going on I was like you know
not that whatever I was I probably you
know at that point I swear to God I
swear to Christ at that point in my life
I had my hair in cornrows I had fully
corn rolled hair and I was just like you
know what's up with you like that you
know like that's how I was and I was
like you know answer the door you know
no shirt were you hanging out with black
dudes or you were down so many times
basketball team so it's like you know
what I thought I needed to do to be the
white kid to fit in it's just what I
thought I I knew it turns out you don't
got to do anything no you don't have to
do anything no because literally no
matter how no matter how much I wanted
to present myself as a black person they
still only ever called me Dirk Nowitzki
or mayonnaise that's all they call so
it's like you're not ever you will never
be one of us no so it's just like fine
but but at least I got I saved myself
from getting made fun of because I could
shoot jump shots and at least I could I
could fit in on the basketball team so
that was my way to like fit in but so
and I have you know took it too far like
most teenagers just do we're idiots so
so my dad uh says to me he goes all
right he goes um he goes what happened
with uh your mom the other day and I was
like can I get back to the the cornrows
thing yes I like you still call them
rolls corn rolls yeah
because I'm used to spinach troll
pepperoni roll like yeah
I have to I have to make everything
Pizzeria friendly for me yeah it goes
well that's it yes
um I like when you're the when you're
doing that you're in that part of your
life
when there's but there are certain white
guys that you'll still be like he's cool
you're like you'll only like publicly
like black guys right but then every
once in a while you'd be like as a white
he's he's all right he's decent yeah for
a white they always play
um when they go what music should we
play for you when I go on and I go
anything but Eminem because that's their
first move right it's like well he's if
he's associate I associate him with bi
people yeah so of course Eminem yeah and
it's so [ __ ] embarrassing yeah you
don't worry like I don't you please any
yeah I'm begging you not to play Eminem
yeah I come out to Whitney Houston
exclusively well of course it's a
[ __ ] you never you never seen that
coming did you see the uh the biopic
trailer oh yeah I think it looks great
do you not like it
there's a snoop biopic that they just
announced now here's my issue okay
you know if you make this new biopic you
know who's not in it snoop snoop right
they it should they used to make
Muhammad Ali biopics and they would just
put him in it yeah you can't do that
they would just put them in it yeah
which I think they should do for Snoop I
really believe that right just put them
like you could do CG do something to
make him because I don't need the NWA
version because Dre's like diesel to use
here thank you uh word [ __ ] diesel yeah
cocktail if we're going through the full
yeah the full German
um the so I think they should just use
the real Snoop Same by the way same
weight he's the same weight he hasn't
gained I can't put a [ __ ] pound on
yeah you're the you're the Snoop Dog of
white guys you're Snoop
very similar dude we've been in it for a
long time man yo seriously in the game
for a long time but let me just let me
just wrap up my dance rope because it's
one of those things where it's like okay
I get that's right intention wrong move
but it might be my intention right I
like that as a premise for the show by
the way yeah yeah I gotta say like as
the what you don't even need to I just
think anything is like a recurring thing
it's like better than just talking be
prepared for me to be calling you weekly
to try to get this one Showdown
um and so you're not even rolling here
right no no no this is lit no dude we
can't talk about this [ __ ] on hey babe
fans don't care about this this is for
me man
um so so so but my dad he goes oh what'd
you say to your mother and I was like I
was like oh I called her a [ __ ] and he
goes why did you say that I was like
because she was acting like a [ __ ] and
then he goes yeah he goes yeah and then
he just punched me in the face like out
of nowhere like like this fist like like
she was 14 like punch me in the face
yeah uh hit me like in the cheek like
punch like where I like fell into the
wall all like literally like into the
wall like like was like stunned like did
not ever in a million years but my heart
was like I'm sure and and then he
grabbed me he grabbed me and he gave and
he gave me like a kiss on the forehead
he goes here's the thing he goes I'm
sorry I had to do that he goes but you
call a woman a [ __ ] you think you're a
man he goes being punched in the face
that's what happens to men if they call
a woman a [ __ ] they get punched in the
face he goes are you a man and I was
like oh I'm not a man he goes exactly he
goes and a real man would never call a
woman a [ __ ] he goes you apologized to
your mother put some ice in your cheek
you're going to be fine he goes don't
ever make me have to do that again you
made me have to do that and I was like
Wow and it was like a fundamental change
where I was like yeah you know what who
the [ __ ] do you think you are Chrissy
and then I swear to Christ they're very
and that's why I remember this the very
next thing is you called your mom ma'am
which I think is a little bit of an over
correct I remember because like the very
next morning I woke up and I just like
looked in the mirror and I was like let
me slowly take out my cornrows and I
slowly took them out and I was like let
me wash my hair and I was like still I
carried myself the same way but I was
like I'm being someone let me stop
wearing double XL everything yeah I was
like this I'm I'm not the guy
I'm gonna buy a belt yeah yeah you know
what it is it's like Chris you can't
have cornrows wear FUBU call your mom a
[ __ ] and also have psoriasis it does
one of these things is not like the
other you know you have you have your
your borderline asthmatic you know
you're scared of the dark you didn't
talk to them you wouldn't talk to your
basketball teammates about this much
your psoriasis and your fear of the dark
yeah
there were huge black talking points for
you no no they didn't they didn't want
to hear about that yeah um but yeah so
it's one of those things where yeah
maybe maybe that is maybe maybe that's
my thing right an attention wrong move
maybe there's something there I don't
know well no it is that's a good it's a
good angle for like you could call it
back five times like you know what the
one thing too the one thing too about
about about your show and it's just like
a life thing too is what I what I got
from it is bro to get to the level of
the stuff you were talking about it's
the thing that I think I subconsciously
do not want to do is it's very very
scary to get to the level of you know
when you get vulnerable and even to find
some of those punch lines it's like yo
you gotta really kind of look at
yourself in the mirror and be like this
is who I am and this is what I'm about
and then material about it and I think
sometimes I personally stop because I'm
like wait I don't want to actually face
the fact that because you could but
you I'll say this you have
opened up a small Lane for yourself
because your anxiety is kind of fun
right like I gotta like you you know but
by the way I was very excited to just be
on Staten Island to see where I'd watch
so many Instagram stories from uh
it's a huge huge deal
um the streets you know where they made
these great Instagram IG lives yeah and
some of the stories and um Chris chaos
Chris anxiety Tuesday whatever this is
but if you came here 10 years ago it was
there were no cameras it was just Sal
giving cute wedgies yeah just on this
Bible History it was just it was Pete
you know with no tattoos yet walking
around with crohn's
um I'm just kind of trying to trying to
get information about Crohn's yeah you
couldn't get it yeah if anyone you know
just worked in a supermarket you know
like it was it was uh before we had
something but you have opened up a small
like you are you've made anxiety like a
silly thing yeah but even the fact that
you talked about it and people responded
to it it's because they also have
anxiety yeah everyone has something so
that's what I realized in terms of like
with three mics and with this one
I people are like aren't you embarrassed
I'm like no I I know what happens right
I say I say it and I get Deluge with
people saying it back so it's like I
just go first right and then everybody
which I'm sure you thought you probably
accidentally said something about
anxiety yeah and then realized like and
then 10 people were like dude [ __ ] I
have it too and then you realize like
We're All in This Club that we don't all
think we're in yeah but you you've done
it
you can like what premise of mine did
you think I wouldn't talk about that
um that what I wouldn't talk about well
the only thing that not not that I not
specifically but I'm just saying like
where you were like [ __ ] I don't that's
a because I don't even know what you
mean the the vulnerable stuff I
understand like the stuff about like I
don't want to get married because I
don't want to or I don't wanna have a
kid because I don't want to maybe not
love it like that's again there's no
punch lines there but I think I think I
think like when I I what I meant was
like you know you have material about
like your dad like genuinely like not
loving you yeah and it's like there was
it was like it was like oh [ __ ] you have
to face that you have to face that head
on and again write bits about it where
it's like that's hard because there
might be things where like there might
be that there because because my mom
would always say you know I like things
like that I didn't ever even uh knew
that she reminds me of she's like you
know you know you she's like you know
Chris you used to uh well I was like go
away don't you think my sense of humor
came from she's like well I noticed when
you were a child like five six years old
every time your father would call to
check in on you you know every night
he'd check in on on you you know he
called from Staten Island we were here
home in Queens Brooklyn she you know
you'd be hysterical a long distance call
back then I know big time of course he's
from a pay phone and he was he was like
you'd always cry you'd always start to
hysterical cry because you missed your
dad so much and then what you would do
is he's just like I got to the point
where I would know she would say I'd say
Chris Sunny Daddy's on the phone and
then I'd hear you whimpering and they'd
always you know you'd start to cry you'd
get so upset and then I'd always keep
your dad on the phone for another minute
because we just knew the routine and
then because what you were thinking of
is how am I going to disguise this from
my father and you would come up with
some kind of joke or some type of silly
story that you made up and trying an
effort to make him laugh and you know
that's how you'd be and I don't even
remember that as a kid there's some deep
deep pain that I have that I talk about
my dad so much there's some deep
insanely deep that I have about my
father that I don't even know how to
articulate yet but it's in there because
I was as a child hysterically crying
what are you he just wasn't around that
was that was the issue you were divorced
and I was upset that my dad couldn't be
in the house with me yeah it would
remind me I would get reminded every
time he called like oh [ __ ] I miss my
dad right because I then I would you
know I'd go to sleep wake up the next
day and be a child and not think about
him until he called me again that night
and I'd be like I also gotta say
I don't not everybody needs to be deep
dude right like right you don't maybe
don't I if you're saying this I'm like I
don't want you to do this yeah yeah like
I don't I really don't yeah I'm like I
don't want to [ __ ] hear this [ __ ]
like just give me [ __ ] funny Maniac
stories yeah just be a maniac yeah
Special Maniac yeah just be a [ __ ]
Maniac you maniac and you barely have
oxygen you [ __ ] like [ __ ] you have
all these like moves yeah and you have
like a voice or brand or whatever you
want to call it just be that like I
don't [ __ ] want you to be Emo yeah
like I just be [ __ ] yeah be a man be
like a guy who's like trying to do the
right thing like that's why I like that
good intentions wrong with like that's a
good
yeah I can see it I like I know that
right well maybe it's two I think like
you you didn't write that in a year
blocks right I mean that this takes time
uh yeah I mean yeah it was I had a
different story because I saw you
working with Jenga blocks in like 2018.
you did yeah like I feel like there was
a bit there was one time you know uh at
zany Chicago there's this guy Brian that
works over there and he was like oh I
saw Neil working with Jenga blocks or
some type of job no that's that Jenga
joke about about talk about trans issues
oh so he's okay so I think he was
talking about that so yeah so Jenga
style he was saying like you know but I
remember you talking something with
Jenga because when he said it that I'm
bringing up him because like I remember
that I did the joke it's about talking
about transitions
so my mind is I was like I know that
I've heard Neil talking about Jenga
stuff no I wrote the show in the show
was sort of written in 2020 and I was
supposed to start in 2020. right and
couldn't and no one knows why yeah but
it's like but it's it's still like a
work of it's still like these things
like everyone tries to get things out so
quickly nowadays because they like I
need more and more and more but it's
like I think think like the ones that
stick out the best are like hey it took
some time yeah
I don't have I don't I my jokes have to
be perfect that's like the downside of
being low Charisma is that is that
my jokes have to be so good
or they just don't work right they
either work or they don't work I can't
[ __ ] squeak I can't wink them out
right like they have to be structurally
so [ __ ] sound so I kind of have to
work for a long time interesting
um the the with the code I was thinking
you were saying about Dr fauci I was on
a dating app and a woman said she was
open-minded okay which I thought she
meant she liked like you know gangbangs
and stuff and then and then she sends me
a [ __ ] fouchy documentary and I'm
like oh that's what you meant by oh my
God yeah I thought we were gonna like
you know do some wild [ __ ] yeah turns
out you just want you just want me to
look at both sides yeah that's what it
is yeah of science
um you gotta look at both of Science and
now there's one side oh you're not
dating now you're single now I am single
yeah but you would like you would why
would I build was in love in February
like it was [ __ ] it's amazing it's
[ __ ] amazing February March right
February to March through full February
full month summer January full February
full March she didn't like the intimacy
Chrissy oh it was her she didn't like
she didn't like that she didn't like it
she was like you're the she actually
said something hilarious she goes you're
the most emotionally available guy I've
ever dated and I don't like it
interesting it was like upside down day
where I was like wait what I'm the and
you're the China uh
yeah we fell in love and she was like
we're [ __ ] dude could you imagine some
of the other guys you dated before you
if you're the most emotionally available
guy I mean monsters shut down monsters
she dated everybody yeah I mean if I'm
if I'm the gold standard [ __ ] no but
dude but you've worked on yourself man
you've talked about the 30s yeah and
then you have video evidence of it it's
[ __ ] wild yeah the video evidence is
kind of rough right yeah like well
because at first I was like oh this is
gonna get funny and then I was like oh
holy [ __ ] the one in China I was like
yeah
the one in China the one in China was
like yo but then with the beauty of this
special again within 30 seconds you're
laughing again yeah but but that moment
I remember while I was doing the dick
because I was watching it on the phone I
remember washing dishes what I'm kidding
yeah you didn't sit out yeah um no I was
watching and I was like I remember that
China thing I was like there's got to be
a bit here but then it was just you're
just getting [ __ ] destroyed by this
Chinese doctor I was like yo I was like
yeah popped yeah popped yeah but um but
but yeah man beautiful we had a couple
of questions from the fans V can you put
that or Mike yeah okay uh worst
celebrity you've ever met and what's the
story eh
um the species oh are you never
returning to the pot big this is from
Peter Laura big meal first off I'm gonna
do a different podcast here's
you'll like this okay
you'll like that I'm doing that again
100 you're gonna really get a kick out
of this
um I'm gonna do Jimmy Carr the Great
British comedian had an idea for a
podcast which is have other people on
and uh podcast and have them talk about
their blocks okay the things that make
them feel isolated and crazy and like
alone in the world like the special so
oh my dude I just realized that's why
it's called blocks
because you have emotional blocks I
thought it was just because it was
[ __ ] blocks like I'm in because
when I saw the special I was like oh I
want to watch blocks I like blocks it
helps I'm learning with pop-up books I
literally was wondering why is he not
responding to this very good idea
they're nodding and you're going like oh
[Music]
I haven't had Hunter before no I get by
on Charisma yeah exactly
um yeah no so well that's what yeah so
it's other people's blocks but I got
good people we'll have you on yeah I got
good people uh don't get too emo because
if people don't want that from you uh
just be a Maniac Okay and uh and so I'm
gonna start that soon I'm just waiting
I'm I just have to get because I don't
want to do a podcast every week because
you see what it does to you
um but I'm already burning out I want to
do like a bunch of them and then like do
10 and then chill and then like a season
yeah I've been saying this yeah I've
been saying this to for for the last
years are more topical this will be like
right Evergreen so to speak and I got
good people that are willing to do it
yeah you get big guests yeah get bought
out by [ __ ] hellofresh oh can you
imagine yeah hello fresh what were they
just doing with cookies great they're
great people oh we love hella we love
hellofresh uh
yeah we love hellofresh
um uh oh if Chris could have played a
role in the Chappelle show who would it
be uh racist cop yeah just a cop right
yeah why not that's one thing yeah you
play that on Chase yeah he literally
texted me the night before two nights
before he goes I exact text he goes I
wrote a part for a racist cop it's funny
there's no one more perfect than you I
was like good except Burr but he
wouldn't have done it yeah he did it he
would do it for you than I could afford
that I can do travel for yeah yeah
um all right well that's that's uh what
is this the overlapping pregnancies of
Nick Cannon's 12 children just a graph
of Nick Cannon's current children count
right with all different women which he
seems to like they're pregnant at the
same time here right but there's no beef
like there's no women coming out of the
woodwork being like oh [ __ ] this guy
he's done it he's done it the right way
yeah
um and by the right way I mean no condom
bareback yes end the episode right there
um
foreign
[Music]